howdy howdy howdy welcome back to mcube
serek and sci-fi Quest you know we're
we're bringing in the New Year the right
way and we're gonna bring it in talking
about a hundred different upcoming
movies according to
IMDb agre to 100 that's a lot it's a lot
Can We Do It IMDb and I didn't see 100
on the
list I believe there are we'll
see include all of them because it
doesn't include all the streaming movies
that are coming ah good point good point
but these will at least be the cinema
releases coming in 2024 and I I think
think it'll be a good one so real quick
before we say our hellos and jump into
this thing I think the rules for the
game thumbs up we like it we think at
least that we will like it thumbs side
as Melvin Said a minute ago we're
probably gonna make a video on it we
don't know exactly what we're going to
feel about it but it's something that we
would like to make a video on good or
bad down
we don't have very high expectations if
we do a head pal that's going to mean uh
we don't know if it's actually gonna
release in 2024 maybe I'm gonna need to
do that yeah I'm it's gonna be weird
with the hat we got I'm G my glasses off
this is this is gonna end up in a trip
to
A&E on which movie it is how do
you not least if we wave our hands I
will write down on a whiteboard and we
will discuss it after the fact White
like a plan y'all do it so how's
everybody feeling real quick signals I'm
going to look like I'm voguing through
this we're gonna be dancing the whole
time way to bring in a new
year right okay then you want me to
throw it
up should
we right little awkward for me because I
need to keep going backwards and
forwards but we can just about see what
we're doing so
I think the most looked forward to one
is the one right there on the top on the
left I think so uh should we roll an
inro before we jump into this yes we can
sir yes we can so because I'm ready
because I'm in production
[Music]
go
sorry I was caught on the music there
for a second happy Rogan
again
um and don't forget to whether which
regardless of which channel you're
watching this on to subscribe to all
three we've got Melvin throw out mate
throw the
ad your it's your channel dude come
on
question as always which you might be
watching this on
anyway but yeah shall we uh jump into
this thing because we got a 100 to go
through so we might shall we try to
speed round it speeding speeding stra
away three so Deadpool 3 that's Deadpool
two was a
bit still liked it but yeah all right
yeah F so we're we're all in agreement
on that number two furiosa Mad Max
Saga really I'm I'm right in the middle
I really hope it
a um schar Theon didn't save the other
Mad Max movie and um and neither did
whose fellas whose names gone out my
head Tom movie Tom Hardy yeah who I love
but he wasn't very good in it either
this is a Mad Max movie without Mad Max
in it it does seem a little
crazy exactly what I wasna say that's
fair that's fair yeah but I'm I'm not
I'm I'm not happy about I'll give it a
go like that I'm like that because it's
gonna be fun making a video for it that
I think so it looks like there's some
CGI in it too and and George Miller's
never been the biggest CGI guy so I'm
kind of intrigued what he's doing I
guess no so mostly in the middle some
down I didn't like I didn't like the the
other one so I I doubt I'm going to like
this much all right well Despicable Me
four up on number three I thought it was
despicably me
14 it probably is there only been
four I think there's other spin-offs I'm
not gonna necessarily watch it but I
think it'll be good for for family and
Stu I like that because um I enjoyed the
first two but you know after two it's
like with anything they usually drop
down after one or two sequels yeah well
I just went to go see migration of movie
theaters a couple weeks ago and they did
the little Vector short right in front
of it and what that's been 12 15 years
since the original movie came out and
that was kind of like the thing that
we've been waiting to be solved I guess
and that's the only thing I remember
so still kicking but Ah that's kind of
where I'm at as well it's
so that is a great quote well number
four Godzilla and Kong the new
Empire yeah so high on my my thumb's up
so high I can't stretch it that can't
even see your thumb show off your
armp yeah I that's gonna be great I
think it's gonna spin off for monik I
think there'll be stuff in monik that
sort of teases us a little bit and even
though I'm a bit there about monik I'm a
bit like that about monik I'm kind of
with you it's it's decent but it's it
hasn't really held me the way I wanted
it to I like monarch more because there
was a guy who did a Who U did videos for
it before it started and he had
supposedly seen the first few episodes
and he was saying that you don't see the
monsters in every single episode and so
far you do
so I'm just glad is you see monsters in
every single episode that's true yeah
not much but you do yeah
Ian love white Russell um I just I just
not as I don't know um it's Cinema
quality can't get me wrong monar is
Cinema quality but yeah I'm not I'm not
I'm not adoring it I like love it
they're even sparing on W Russell and
Kurt Russell I I would think they would
have utilized especially having paid
these actors to to do a little more on
the screen you know and they never
appear together what's the point you got
a father and son working together and
they don't appear in the
same if you haven't watched it you've
got no clue it's the same person ignore
me move on Um Kingdom of the Planet of
the Apes yeah up number five West really
oh I
okay because I like the plan of the Apes
films I think they look really good well
made but
obviously it's l it's lacks luster right
now with the plan of the eight films but
it's been a few years long I think it
looks really good
Thea I I am a big fan of the director I
I'm just fingers crossed this is going
to be good one I'll be honest I've not
seen any of them really recent one have
been Matt re guy that did the Batman so
they they're they're good quality but
they just it's been a couple years
everybody liked but for the most part I
believe but interesting number six Joker
fly ad do really I know it's a musical
oh but okay it's I'm in I'm in I I've
forgotten it's a musical in that case
it's
it's it's it's beneath the
sewers no I actually like the first one
um no hated it absolutely hat I thought
it was
stupid I'm I'm the Joker I can dance I
don't care the only thing that was good
was when he shot
UMO dairo yeah I quite like that bit the
rest of it was he's how is this man
anything he's got a girlfriend that he
imagined all the way through because
that didn't make him like Joker crazy
they just made him [__] crazy um and
he got beat up a lot how is this man a
you know terrifying super
criminal it's I just found it crap like
honestly I just I hated it I could not
understand all the fuss I know it was
different but I couldn't understand all
the took ages to watch the first one so
looking to it oh all right well you like
it don't you Harris don't you har I
loved it it's depressing it is just like
Peter said but I think it's good I think
it's Harris likes but when I've seen it
i' no not that good it happens I I I I
mean I tend to like more movies than I
dislike movies though I try to find
something that I do like that's the
actor side of you is it you're part of
the industry so you see it in a
different way to everyone else well yeah
but there are a lot of cynics in this
industry and I I am I might be pragmatic
but I'm not authentic typically I'm an
optimist I'm I'm I'm your happy bastard
just walking around typically but try to
be try to be uh I mean it was a really
depressing movie uh I I I'm just I like
Todd Phillips as a director did
something different I think it was a
good origin story it's not necessarily
he's The Mastermind just yet and it's
kind of how he starts getting there how
he got cuckoo enough to do it I guess
um but I do I like lady go as an actress
that's really what I'm excited about
this next one everything she hasn't been
in a whole bunch but she's really good
in the few things that she has been in I
guess I haven't seen that new American
Horror Story and I'm not necessarily
super interested in it uh but the one
that she did was really good and then in
Bradley Cooper's a stars
born I mean there's a reason she got an
Oscar for the song right I don't
know she she good but
that I think we're all varying on that
one kind of like that we'll see we'll
see strong feelings oppos strong oh
which is kind of good it makes an
interesting movie to talk about at the
very least but andong haris it's just
it's all I don't understand why it
always has to be you I mean be right
occasionally yeah every now and then
every now and
thenen right twice a day so that's true
yeah yeah that's true um Mark Mark has
pointed out is this supposed to be a
speed run yeah we should get moving uh
number seven is wicked that might also
be just a
weird but yeah
okay interesting but I don't know if we
needed a movie on it National Treasure
three is number
eight this is my
first this is my first Bas bomb when I
look I don't think it'll come
out um but
yeah if it justes come out I like the
first two to be fair I if it does come
out it would be a thumbs up I still
think it's a face bom but I
think after the TV show that's that's a
whole another topic anyway yeah TV show
number nine AC quiet plays day
one filming this right now I don't think
this is coming out in 2024 um but it if
it does come out hell yeah the first two
are great fantastic movies all right
number 10 Garfield movie I love Garfield
favorite when I was a kid I always love
Garfield really
Melvin love Garfield I and Chris Bratt I
honestly he doesn't need to be the voice
of everything but I'm happy when he does
it Chris Pratt would be the only reason
why I watch
it I like him as an actor I think he's
pretty good I he's he's good voice actor
is just as good honestly it's kind of
fun number 11 gladiator
who only 18 years later no no like 20
years later literally it's been too long
Russell Crow eats another
hamburger it's I
mean I'm not is Russell Crow even in the
movie I don't think he is
no it would be good if he did eat
another Hamburg that'd be fun spoiler he
died at the end of the first one oh yeah
he does maybe it's gonna CGI it it's
gonna be some of the story in
between well it's supposed to be the son
of the emperor I
believe yeah I I just really like the
cast they have going but it's going to
be kind of similar to Napoleon in the
aspect that I think we'll get a two two
and a half hour film and it's really
going to be a three and a half Four Hour
film that he's going to release a year
after that's my guess because he said
that it was already 90 minutes from what
he's already put together before they
went back to film from what they filmed
pre- strike
yeah was already 90 minutes cut together
God's sake and Peter just made the point
there run out of ideas oh God yes y we
should do was Gladiator was popular we
do that isn't that why we're getting
most of the ones we're getting now it
does see well part of it is I think he
did an original idea a couple years ago
with I can't even think of the movie's
name right now it had Ben Affleck Adam
Driver uh Jody comr and a couple other
people and it was it was a really good
movie uh Matt Damon as well and nobody
would see saw it at all and I guess he
put out he put uh not Ford versus
Ferrari what what was the movie The
House of Gucci I guess that same year
and that was his more popular movie but
it got shadowed the the good movie got
overshadowed by house of Gucci which
kind of sucked but you know not which
Gucci
yeah Kung Fu
panda4 has it really only been three so
far well that TV show that's lasted many
years and it's got a great cast and it's
got a lot of good ratings it's never
been low-rated but I'm just not as
excited as I used to could be good I
love black chances
are we'll
see yeah but number 13 lucky number 13
Bob Marley One
Love I can't say anything about that
because I used to love listening to Bob
mly I'm a reggae fan it was my number
one genre this year and as it always is
is I'm
pumped u i I'll I'll probably watch it
at some point but I've no interest in it
at all I'll see when it's on Sky Cinema
or Netflix whatever so well I'll pump it
up whenever it comes out if it's good
enough to convince you to go I've seen
all five of his kids in
concert but 14 The Fall Guy
it's my wife bought me the complete
original box set there for Christmas
last year and I watched all of them and
um I love it very very much and Lee mes
is is is properly and they should have
just dug Le mes out if he Lee mes he got
to be in this film at some point and I'm
sure he will be but um yeah I think this
looks pretty cool I'm quite I'm quite
liking it I do think they've miscast it
I don't know why they've got that I
don't know why that guy is even an actor
and I've forgotten his name the blonde
guy Ryan goling Ryan Gosling I think
he's the worst actor mate I think he's
got no Charisma he's just
good-look he's he's the the least
charismatic actor um I just don't I just
don't particularly like him
um but
you Lee mes is not the best thing about
the Fall Guy and I know exactly where
Pet's brain is going with that one and
he's 100%
right she was lovely um but yeah uh no I
love the Fall Guy I'm looking forward to
seeing but if they haven't got the truck
in it and they haven't got Lee Maes
doesn't turn up at some point um it's a
it's a mistake I thought he was dead I
just looked it up real quick he's he's
82 he's still kicking but he's he's
still here yeah he's still alive hey
Harrison Ford can be deaged 30 years to
play a long movie anything's on the
table
honestly but speaking about anything
being on the table number 15's Madam
web it'll be a good video but I'm almost
closer to
this I'm gonna do that but it's a
hopeful
I actually think the um trailer looks
okay and I'm trailer is the thing that
hurt me the most about it uh I think
Marvel have turned a corner I I think
but oh it's it's hopeful it's really
going all of my common sense is going do
that do that you idiot I'm looking
forward to with Madame web is all the
YouTube videos that will trash it which
they will they are
entertaining the hate clickers will be
smash it anyway because it will and
chances are well let's hope that they're
wrong but I do hope I mean Dakota
Johnson is a great actress I I I just
don't know if she can lead the ensemble
in the way that they've set it up it
it's just yeah it's it feels like
another one of these Sony Marvel movies
that should be
about Peter Parker and Peter Parker is
nowhere to be seen I I guess he might be
like part of the subplot but I don't
know new predat yes um there is there a
new Predator coming out I don't think
this year but I think they're planning
on filming it this
year I know the what's his name the the
director for prey he wants to
tractenberg Dan tractenberg he wants to
do the'll be a
pre pre
too um there's loads of rumors about it
that it there's one that's going to be a
follow on from pray direct follow on um
but apparently there's a bunch of people
that aren't massively happy about that
and what they and they're worried that
it's going to wander into the silly
because there is a comic book basically
already well yeah no prey was great I
like movie don't get me wrong yeah it's
there there's a rumor that basically the
aliens were going to come the Predators
and make her a like an honorary penor
which has got a name which I forgot what
it is which is from Legends there
Legends
um but apparently Dan tackenberg isn't
massively happy about that the other
option is it's it'll be a World War I
Predator story which I think that is the
way to do it that'd be my favorite do
this through historical events I mean I
think it's genius do that that's my
favorite idea about it thousand but
there are Executives that think no it's
got to have mud blood you know she did
such a good job it's got to follow on
let's have the and then there's other
people going no no no this isn't going
to work so we'll see what they do as
long as they don't go a Viet arm one
because that would just be a remake of
Predator wouldn't it pretty much which
would be okay um but but yeah they could
do I mean but I wouldn't go straight to
World War I though I would like I think
there's other things they could do but
um but
yeah we'll see
yeah yep well now moving on to number 16
The Arc and the Ard
varc I I go see movies all the time but
it's still just kind of uh it's one I've
seen the trailer before but it's not
something that's interested me I mean I
went to go see my Gra I'll go see I mean
I started out the year last year with
Puss and Boots which was an amazing way
to start out the year that was a great
movie but and migration was a good one
too but nothing interesting about this
one necessarily not nothing jumps
no number
if right is this the one that is about
the
imaginary
animals things and one of them is
invisible is Ryan Reynolds in this or I
believe so
um I've seen the trailer for this I
actually think it looks quite good I'm
yeah I'm a thumbs up on it I'm okay with
because I haven't seen the trailer but
if it's got Ryan Reynolds I'll watch it
anyway I think it's Ry somebody like
that I'm not sure it's Ryan Reynolds now
but I remember seeing the the actor
Falls over and says who has an invisible
invisible friend and and then walks
off it's like there there's more than
it's like a bunch of imagin imaginary
things I believe yeah yeah but I'm I'm
fancying that I'm up for that
and our I'm about to say number 18 gives
two thumbs up for me all day yeah I
think this looks
good I I love the director I love the
cast be cool but number 10 Spider-Man
beyond the
spider-verse yeah I well yeah I don't
think it'll come out but um the others
have been great so I don't think there's
any reason to not think this is going to
be brilliant to be honest but I'm with
you on that I don't think it'll come out
I don't think it'll be 2024 it'll get
pushed back in the next month or two 25
at the earliest I think at the very
earliest I think it'll be 2026 honestly
probably pushed yeah
definely could be well number 20 inside
out
numeros um I like the first
one I'd watch it I'm not going but I'd
watch it it it it looks good I just
still haven't seen the first one I feel
bad but I haven't one so everything I've
ever heard is it's amazing I just
haven't taken the time to sit down and
watch it I need to I will before this
one of course but same yeah 21 Tiger's
Apprentice I don't know anything about
this is this another um spin-off of Cony
Panda or something uh it kind of looks
like it I'm not honestly not sure what
this one is either um so I'll put it in
the middle
well some of them we don't even know
about well it goes in your brain but
your brain just goes don't care throw
that away yeah see it because you don't
want to see it yeah well dagger will be
a middle for me just because I don't
know what to do about it
but number 2022 20 2022 I even said the
year wrong 22 itself Sonic the Hedgehog
3 it gets a thumbs up know I would the
first two good but sort of film I'd got
out my way to watch I like I like the
first I'm a fan of both of them give me
a little more Jim Carry anything I just
please K killed yeah he killed he always
kills to but yeah he's he was amazing
he's he's one of I think the top 10
actors that every movie he makes tends
to make at least $150 million he always
F roll like a glove
basically I mean he melds himself
perfectly to anything and everything
just like does with that Clint Ewood
face I love it uh but number 23 Knives
Out
Three it's between
this depends the qu rushing they feel
like they're rushing
these it feels like the first one was so
popular now they rush they rushed the
second one and it wasn't great and then
that feels like they're rushing the
third one was the the second one was was
it 2022 or 2023
uh I think it 2022 I think it's end of
2022 I think so yeah that gives him a
little bit of time still just a little
too close I'm with you there I think it
was just one of those things it was a
surprise hit so now they're like oh
people look let's do more of that and I
just Netflix bought it for $270 million
or whatever it was for the other
two got to meet a quota at that point I
guess but shoot doesn't make they're
getting any better 202 thank you soar um
but number 24 while we're at it 2024
number 24 now I got the years right the
Hunchback of
notredame
notam I don't is it is
it it's gonna turn out that he start the
fire that's how the film's GNA end he's
he's actually a firear theight Shalon
twist firear
twisted yeah um we're dancing a lot
we're dancing a lot in this video yeah
it's kind of fun honestly we got to
bring in the new year with some life you
know be saying that but still but
Hunchback no don't care w't watch it
watch middle of the road if it's a
Disney movie I I guess I'll watch the
liveaction version of it just for peing
of the interest and that's about it I
would do that for a lot of Disney movies
that's true too though that is that's a
good
point I do hope I do hope that they're
going to change things because uh what
Bob 's been saying lately I hope they're
G I hope he does make those changes but
I doubt they will I don't know if it's
going to be immediate just because they
still have such a long lineup of things
not a long lineup I guess now we'll be
looking at any changes being made it'll
be 2026 at the earliest I think in the
next couple yeah for sure it doesn't
matter what decisions they make now
you've got projects that are in
production for two years yeah yeah we
still have the J projects going on
honestly the new Ray Star Wars yeah yeah
so so
no so we're at the quarter Mark here 25
Untitled Venom sequel even if it is a
I'm g
go I do not like these movies I like the
Venom movies I like the Venom I think
they're just dark enough and the second
one could have had done a lot more work
but I do like them this is feels like
another one it feels a bit like the
Transformers that they've got a
perfectly good film there but then
they've got a [__] editing it
or writing it sometimes I if it's
written like that that's worse than the
the editors but it feels like it's cut
together badly but then the writing is
terrible I I keep bringing up this one
thing about how Venom walks in sees the
red venom goes ah red one not me I'm out
of here and then Mark Tom hard just goes
ah go on he goes oh all right then they
don't explain that joke at
all um you now
I appreciate those movies for Tom
Hardy's acting ability and what he tries
to bring to the role I just I haven't
been a fan of the the writing and then
much of anything and then Andy Circus
made me so excited for the second one
and it's the one thing on Andy Circus
his entire repertoire that just hurts my
soul I will say one thing about Venom he
really needs to control his black
goo it goes everywhere even at the end
of no way home in the post credit scene
a bit on the bar
why does he leave it lying around
everywhere it was poop yeah you
know um number
26 petle juice
2 I'm like that but with a massive risk
this could be bloody awful that's why
I'm like that because and oh I'm so
hopeful I'm like M are being lifted up
by hope is it bad that Tim Burton is the
thing that worries me and excites me the
most about it
it's bang on look look what he did with
Wednesday the man can make a film yeah
he still got it um but then he can do
some utter garbage as well A Nightmare
Before Christmas still causes me pain
not because it's a bad film necessarily
but it should have been so much better
and I just kind of think Tim Burton he
Tim Burton it that that film should have
been epic it was such a good idea and
Tim Burton and uh Still Still pains me
and yes Sarah Michael Keaton
is lots of the original
cats oh yes I I'm I'm pump for that one
I I think we're all pumped to I think he
had so much fun making it he had no
choice but to say yes yeah yeah yeah
Keon's always said it's his favorite
role or if not his favorite Ro in top
two it's that and Birdman and can you
blame him
like
but yeah so where that excitement just
was shall it be squandered with number
27 Kella number two no I liked it I like
the first one oh my God you're both
wrong you morons the first I can't but
do you know what I like it and i' I've
forgotten her freaking
name much Emma Emma
Stone she was amazing
she was so she was great but you cannot
tell me that's the same character that
turns into the corilla DeVille that we
all know and grew up with well no but
it's like a Multiverse kruella yeah but
I'm okay with that I just it it was
really good um and um I would watch the
second
one I'll probably still watch it just
for the sake of watching it but but but
em just she's just I'm kind of a palm
with it I just don't know if it'll come
out honestly
this year at least uh yeah well
everything this year is going to be
little if it's not actually already
finished filming it says pre-production
right there so that means it hasn't even
started fman no chance yeah maybe early
2026 well speaking of I thought it was
26 I thought that was gonna be a nice
little segue it's number 28 I can read
sometimes it's a little far away Mortal
Kombat two
dos i i yeah I'm on board I thought the
first one was
honestly just no expectations I went
into it expecting a terrible movie um
car's just Carrie thank you so much for
the donation I love you thank you very
much but you've misspelled always you
you've spelled it t h i n k s when you
meant Jame is just always right um I so
I just had to correct that there silly
Bly real quick Mark said he watched
kruella on acid and enjoyed it it was
great and then that was it was not the
acid talking because he watched Thor
four on acid and that was an awful
movie that is
actually on
any thing why is he talking to the
Hammer that would be oh trippy
but but no an
rated Mortal Kombat for sure I I'm in
for it it's kind of a turn your brain
off movie but I'm okay with that
th% 29 The Sword and the stone it's not
happening not this year what it say
chance not happening yep I'm with you no
move on f
[Music]
f it's supposed to be a prequel signal
for why why is it that
why
why I'm getting [__] out
here the Maleficent 3 is the next one
why 31 is Maleficent 30 is the same
thing you gotta do like that actually
hav't I why pre-production I the first
Maleficent was decent the second
Maleficent I think I watched I don't
remember if I did I'm pretty sure I did
but it's notable enough I don't think it
deserved a second one yet alone a third
to be
honest Angelina I can't even say her
name right Angelina
Jolie as Maleficent and that's about
where the where the movie fell you
know and again completely changed the
character you're on about ly yeah it's
it's she's not some anti-hero she's
going to end up a very bad person later
on so if you want to bring in a dark
character let that character be dark
it's okay you know it's okay
people whatever I don't know number 32
is I don't I don't know what that is
Step dude nothing about it so it says
pre-production so I give it a
face just don't I've never heard of
it no idea what it is it sounds like it
might be something like Ashton Kutcher
would do hey you the Dude Where's My Car
number two if he needs a sequel I I'll
help out but step sounds like something
that would
be you know AR they actually working on
the
sequel if they
are campaign get your photo in sure it's
a strong rumor I
think we've got 28,000 amazing
subscribers over on SRE and we will all
rally for Harry to uh get that part you
need it sir and that would get me the
part of Aris Bach Jr or the third
something like that that's the go why
not we're working on it you know
manifesting this stuff in
2024 but moving on from 32 number 33 is
Juliet I believe it's like a just the
Juliet from Romeo and Juliet it says
pre-production but I think it's it might
be far along far enough along to keep
moving
but I don't um if I get in a lot of
trouble with my wife and on Valentine's
Day we need to watch a movie I might
watch it if I don't get trouble with my
wife on Valentine's Day I won't have to
do you get in trouble with your wife for
falling asleep during a movie you don't
like whil you're watching it I fell
asleep during notebook and she moaned
that I
snored well best part of the movie yep
yeah oh for me it was I had a lovely nap
it was lovely but anyway fast and loose
is this a Fast and the Furious movie I
don't think so I think it's a it says
action and crime Thriller Oh I thought
it was a comedy action and crime
Thriller definitely look like f faster X
part two yeah I feel like I've heard of
it but it also says pre-production so
I'll just be safe and give it jump ahead
Rush Hour four what the Yeah well that's
gonna be we'll get to that in a minute
oh yeah 35 the council no nothing about
it move on to NSTAR
y
big good as long as it's a true remake
of the original like they say it's
supposed to be
I think it'll be scarier than the
original it'll be slightly be scarier
modern standards but as long as they
keep to the premise of the
original I think it's G of a feel of it
as well to be honest they've worked
really hard on the aesthetic of this
film and um and I think they've from
what I've seen this could be good oh
yeah Robert Edgar does not half ass
anything he doesn't three quarters ass
anything he full asses everything so
thank you Robert eggars that's not just
saying it is
now oh God by well moving on to 37 but
this one with Jam Lee Curtis and
everybody when are we getting a moonfall
two I hope
no no remember who's in it but
I thumbs up just I like this is supposed
to be filming now and this the CTI the
post production on this is going to be
at Le 18 months so it's not
happening but 36 Rush Hour 4 they
haven't filmed it yet so it is gonna be
a palm head for me but I it's it's a
double freaking thumbs up Chris Tucker
and Jackie Chan are both back it's as
they're as long as they're back it'll be
kind of like that because they're
getting on the third one was Jackie
hasn't been the same love the jack a
while
I liked the um I liked all the the post
credit scene with Chris Ducker messing
up constantly and kept calling the
character Jackie yeah that's a that's a
Jackie Chan must I think every movie
he's been in should have that because
yeah in his old stuff he had when he
jumped on hovercraft he broke his ankle
andum that tray I jumped in the tray in
Armor of God and fell and smashed his
skull open he get stuck in the in the
great when he goes through the yeah
sliding down that glass building going
through that whatever movie Lord man I
think I think at one point he he wasn't
able to get insured but he wouldn't do a
movie without doing his own stunts
yeah great actor great
actor understand him great St man great
St 39 Mickey 17 big old thumbs up we're
scii premise of this I do like the
premise of this it sounds interesting
I'm not a massive Robert Patterson fan
Pattinson
there is one movie called Mickey that
I'm interested in finding out more about
have you heard of Mickey
Mouse the horror
movie now St uh what's it um steamboat
Mickey
will yeah
yeah we'll
see hat are they redoing cat and hat
don't care don't
care if it who oh is it liveaction like
Mike Meers last one or is it animated if
it's animated I'll give it a thumbs up
if it's not I'll watch
it I I won't I anyway
41 it hasn't started filming yet so it's
kind of a
a is that this is not 2024 this is going
to be 2025 likely the time
hopefully 42 Community the movie did
y'all watch Community the TV show no
don't know anything about it's funny
it's a good one it's where Donald Glover
became Donald Glover outside of just
being I guess Childish
Gambino okay prove his
chops good good cast I I would want
Chevy Chase to come back but I don't
know if that's the case he kind of got
kicked off but you know it's it's Chevy
Chase bring him back for a movie yeah uh
oh it's that show is it oh okay I know
right 43 perfect no idea what it is but
pre-production I'm give it a faceb is
this the is this wrestling
again is it I'm not sure I might be
making it up says biography drama and
Sport oh yeah that would make sense
biography drama sport that sounds like a
wrestling thing Google Perfect movie
it's not coming up it won't come up with
it perfect movie 2024 maybe I don't know
yeah
um but if it is a wrestling movie as
much as I enjoyed the ironclaw I'm GNA
give everybody a top 10 top 15 list here
soon from
2023 very high up there it's a gymnast
it's a movie about gymnast so no
watching that dead shot I watch oh dead
yeah Deadshot is that that's not DC is
it that's not
DC I'm Googling we're getting into lower
numbers now we don't know what the
bloody hell are well it says an so I'll
give it a face pal uh it was supposed to
well there was one out in 2023
apparently oh that was um Netflix I'm
give a wait and
see it is not a DC
movie um it's a British movie and it
stars loads of British
[Music]
actors Colin Morgan Tom vaugh lawyer
Mark Strong who's always brilliant Andy
Jones oh fisty Jones is a babe um but
yeah so oh to Sky original it'll be
crap terrible that British yeah thumbs
up but then sky sky John was saying if
they can pull off the Bioshock movie as
good as the last video game adaptation
will be great agreed did you see Twisted
Metal By the way anybody on peacock it
was it was peac but yeah it was good
actually quite enjoyed it I I have not
played those games and it made me want
to go play them it was a lot of fun it's
a it's a brain off M type of series but
yeah it was good I
enjoy that guy head go get crushed or
whatever F it's the original riders for
Deadpool which makes total sense at what
it's 100% that yeah but number 45 muscle
action
comedy is that who's that on the poster
um Ain diesel so um I watch it for the
sake of it yeah I mean I think Vin
Diesel tends to do good stuff I know his
production company's producing this
again it's in it's not goingon to be out
this year but um this is another one
supposed to started filming like six
months ago um but um but but yeah I I I
only know about
this have they started filming if it
says pre-production
not necessarily they might have done
some like location shots or something
like that but it's not going to be
anything like substantial by any means
preu generally means getting ready to go
into production um but I only know about
this because I keep watching about um
the um Chronicles of ridic and stuff the
ridic sequel [__] doing and I read about
number 46 just I hope this excites him
enough back like into action movies that
aren't Fast and Furious like normal just
go gung-ho Punchy punch action movies
that it will make Chronicles a ridic his
just baby right after and I'm I I like
the Fast and Furious is dying out by
technicality but also just slowing down
and reaching its end so he can jump onto
some ridic because I love some R be good
Chronicles R in particular was my one of
my favorite movies that I mean they're
not great but they're so much fun
Chronicles is the the second ridic was
basically just a remake of pitch black
which I found a bit irritating um I
wanted to see another Chronicles film
but that they put Pitch Black in The
Chronicles of Ric
series because it's not actually a ridic
movie you know R is in it but yeah bad
boys bad boys what you gonna do what you
gonna do if it come for you thumbs up
thumbs up that's what girls from the
series was okay is it gonna feature the
girls from the series
oh okay oh wait say that again sorry
what series there was a bad boy
series oh yeah they did is it out yet is
it gonna feature them that's a good
question because it did feature some of
the people from Bad Boys 3 am I right or
no because that was bad boy series that
got cancelled but it wasn't called Bad
Boys was it but it was they changed it
it was um direct link it was it was a
it's been can spinoff uh was it B
girls I remember who's in it as well the
one woman famous
Oh's in the screen I remember the I just
don't remember exactly who's in or what
it was about I watched I only got about
halfway through the first season I got
bored I didn't love it but it got
canceled anyway but I didn't number 47
the angel face it's announced I don't
know what it is but it's announced so
I'm G give was it a
drama does yeah drama drama yeah yeah
yeah I'm not entirely sure but drama
drama got enough drama in my own life
thanks
yeah this one's filming at least is this
animated or is this this can't be it's a
straight up movie again um it's a live
action um I can't remember the guys
who's who's in it let me give me a
second tell you who's in it it's I don't
know the guy Jess Alber Jessica Alber it
was Jessica Alber you Legend um yeah
it's Jack KY who's who I don't know is I
don't know who he is it's basically a
bunch of actors I've never heard of
um uh Millennium Media are making it in
Dark Horse
entertainment I like dark warse it's got
to be better than the last one I would
hope
so read read the chat from from douge
Jay where's douge I'm on the other page
one second Jay please read the chat from
douge
um hey guys I love the channel can I get
a shout out today is my wife and her
boyfriend's
anniversary
no so unlucky wait
wait boyfriend and her boyfriend's
anniversary well doie
actually we got it
yet
congrats it's his wife and her
boyfriend's
anniversary yeah yeah that's what I'm
laughing about oh okay seem to get it I
thought you didn't get it shout out to
douge
[Music]
P um number
49 Crim
Shaw I know a lot of CRM Shaws and it's
it's a kind of a Cajun kind of Southern
name so I'm I'm going to say yes I don't
know what it is but it's announ so I'm
also going to do this yeah it's not um I
actually think this's gonna get
cancelled really interesting last thing
I but number 50 Lord of the Rings The
War of
rerum yeah I think you've said that
wrong I think it's the war of
rum yeah it's that's the correct Elven
pronunciation
I would hope the Brits could get some
talking right but so it was actually
written down by someone who had a
stutter in his
writing I think it's somebody who's got
a Scrabble and they got oh my God these
letters are
terrible these the worst F again got
nine RS what the hell am I gonna do with
this right how many dictionaries have
you got in the library we're going to
look through every single one find out
that means ble of I think this gonna be
cool I'm bumped I I I I like The Witcher
anime that they did a couple years ago
this is not the same people by any means
but I like the the continuation of the
concept yeah so big old thumbs 51 the
ministry of ungentlemanly
warfare I've seen a couple of bits on
this and I've actually spoken somebody
that worked on it I think it's going to
be very very interesting um and it's all
about SP
and what have you but it I think it'll
be very interesting it sounds cool I'm
I'm in I'm in Melvin did
you I don't know don't know anything
about it so sorry sorry I don't know
anything not really I probably saw
something on it but I just don't
remember it it's not
memorable well number 52 is courage it
says sci-fi and it says announced the
Sci-Fi aspect I watch it for the sake of
it whenever it does come out but for it
being announced it good enough faceb for
it being SciFi
definitely let me come back to that in a
second because I know something about
this but I can't remember what it is so
give me a second I just need to look it
up and then it'll it'll the main well
this next one's gon to be an easy one I
think so we we'll keep on going until we
we know what courage is about 53 is
ballerina a John Wick
story I
thought Anna armas it's the same
producers same writers I mean
oh that's because Matthew Vaughn sorry
courage is being produced by Matthew
Vaughn that's why I know about it uh
yeah uh this is going to be really
interesting yeah I'm just trying to uh
remember what what was
about a war drama in the same sort of
vein as Inception or Edge of
Tomorrow
um yeah this that I yeah I I know
somebody that knows a little bit about
it and they've said this this is going
to be very interesting definitely that
then he's going to a Sci-Fi sort of
thing but he's doing he's Michael Vaughn
in it so it'll be different interesting
ballerina I'm I'm okay with ballerina my
only issue because I'm I'm I'm getting a
bit with the um John Wick movie you
haven't been a big fan of John Wick's
expansion of the world one was so good
but I tell you what the um the series
they did was mindly
boring um I I think I only got through I
barely got through the first episode The
the first episode sucked the second
episode was significantly better and I
actually really did enjoy the third
episode but it it wasn't Perfect by any
means maybe I'll give it another go but
no I was not enjoying it um okay what's
the next film called Harris Berserker so
do youall know anything about berser
Berserker do you know anything about it
not really is it an anime this is kananu
Reeves Pet Project right here he wrote
this comic book alongside a couple other
people but he was one of the main
writers he's the the characters based
off of him and like his kind of badassy
and movies and all that kind of stuff so
this is like his his pet project it's a
double thumbs up for me I'll give it a
go I don't really know much about it but
I love anything sh Reeves
do um number 55 The Good
Fortune action comedy that sounds fun
but pre-production I'll give it a a head
bomb don't know about Good Fortune after
The Beekeeper I'm gonna go watch it next
weekend can't wait straighten Phil well
hopefully can get some buzz on
it it's good have a good
to it was perfectly just slid in there
I I'm not having a coffee
with I'm pum for it anything Jason STM
besides the Meg I guess I didn't
watch Jason at the moment I don't think
he's said as good as he was
before I don't as
hard um tell me how to get how to get to
Sesame
Street at 57 what y'all
think I said I go see a lot of movies
especially the kid movies uh I'll still
go see them just because you know you
gotta keep the kid and you reinvigorated
but Sesame Street might be a little
little too young for the kid and me so
I'm I'm not watching this it might be
okay but I'm not watching it um but all
I keep thinking is this I want to sneak
on Before Christmas next year I want to
sneak onto the set and kill big bird
because that would be a tasty Christmas
dinner you know every time I do my
turkey I'm always little bit
disappointed how much meat is on
there big bird that would be that I
could feed the 500 with that so that's
Christmas Laura said no singing
Jay you're getting getting in trouble
around here noting in J
copyright no loveing the Hat Harris
loveing the Hat um I will sing and you
will like it so I grew up on this hands
off the bird HED tomb is gonna gonna get
you some tough dry meat there snuffle up
against
Revenge he runs round loads and I'm
pretty sure it's like organic so that is
a that is a good I think that'd be good
eating and whoever gets I'm being the
Daddy get that Wing like come
on if you do cook up big bird I call a
wing Ashley can I can I get a
leg
that's but 5 uh 58 I thought it was 56
for a second there 58 Maxine y'all
probably aren't big horror people but
these first two have been great great
tai9 is there for a reason oh no it is
it is her this the person that the main
movie was followed up by a prequel which
was literally it's interesting cuz the
one ladies played like all of these same
characters kind of deal and she's
playing the this is going to be a sequel
to the original movie called X which was
a porn filming movie but it was a horror
movie don't have anything to do with it
kid Cy was in it it was it was what got
Jenna Ora the job for Wednesday and all
these other things it was her big movie
before that and most people that watch
the kid show on Wednesday is uh or at
least they probably haven't seen X but
it was fantastic can I just suggest that
as we're as as time is ticking on and
we're only at 59 and we're now getting
into films that we've never heard of
should we just sort of start skipping
through these a bit now yeah just be
quick about the ones we don't know yeah
oie for voice of the forest I don't know
why it's in this list it came out like a
month ago yeah so and I'm not watching
60 What About Love NOP not watching that
either know what it is so I'll put it
middle not a r
biography Drama head bom Lords of War
big up but it's pre-production so
probably is it Lord is this a sequel to
Lord of War because that was good yeah
it is okay cool Old Guard to I'll give
it first one sh mate you could what you
could put shice Thon in a star treer
Musical and I will still watch
it
love she's amazing
she Star Trek
musicals he doesn't like musicals
especially Star Trek musicals no I like
music Wonka might be my okay I like a
musical I don't mind a musical but I
want the songs to be catchy and I don't
want it to be in Star Trek I don't see
why that's a
problem I haven't seen Star Trek but I
kind of agree with you undying love
people liked it some people it's very
separated though people either loved it
or hated it and people get angry either
side but I just I didn't hate it I just
don't think it should have been allowed
to be the ninth episode of the Season it
should have been
like shouldn't even been in the season I
agreed with you and it should have been
a
special you can ignore it then you can
just like go
anyway some
fun never heard of undy love so hot
air undying love I'll give it a thumbs
up just because I watch everything hot
air if it's announced pal
well it
does formul Formula 1 is gonna be epic I
think is that Colin
Ferell uh no Brad Pit isn't it oh oh oh
that's mind that's right big big yep big
yep yeah I think it's gonna be awesome
um they're doing loads of it's going to
be barely any CGI that all the guys have
actually had to like learn how to drive
it's going to be epic they said it's one
of the most dangerous films they've ever
made it's incredibly dangerous but I
think just sometimes I'm so excited done
got be done but 67 girls trip to uh yeah
now the first one is fantastic I assume
both of you seen girl strip I I have not
oh Epic movie I've not seen
it I haven't seen it but I don't like
the title so not
not um no uh uh 68 last breath I'm not
sure what that is it says post-
production though so it might come out
so it says drama I I I watch everything
so I'll give it a thumbs up yeah Lelo
and Stitch big old thumbs up that's
that's my
generation L and Stitch yeah yeah and if
anything was gonna be a good liveaction
Disney thing Lilo and Stitch Has the
concepts and the story to do it
and it's got the fun creatures it's like
I've heard about it it's gonna be like
Oh I'm I'm hoping this generation of
sci-fi Fanatics I'm gonna give this a go
but oh this could be bad it could be
really bad but I'm really hoping it just
brings the new generation of scii I love
Le Stitch Le Stitch is fantastic I love
the
series land of bad at number 70 can't
see
yeah just just a standard action movie
is that the stars and stripes in the
background of that image um no I think
it's a candy striper oh right okay it's
a candy wrapper yeah oh it's one of
those pick and mix bags that we used to
be able to
getx it kind of looks like a bunch of
Swords or something put together too
fighting over um W with pi mix
sweets yeah it's worth it honestly if
there ever was war that was worth it
that's the one yep good film number 71
the childhood history plan
pre-production so maybe but it's a
comedy I watch a comedy
romcom I do love a romcom I do love a r
comedy family romcon I probably not
gonna like that but um that that George
Clooney one was
good uh and Julia Roberts that was good
no on Swift horses never heard of it I
mean yep I've never heard of it but
twisted
number 73 gets it that I'm interested in
because it's supposed to be an upd up
upgrade for twisters from 96 for me
that's a cinema movie though you've got
to go watch that in
IMAX gonna be big epic that'll be it
could also be just as bad as the Lelo
and Stitch movie could be bad though and
that's what my hesitation with it is but
I really hope it's good if they pay omaj
and honor Bill Paxton fingers crossed
I'll be very happy I'm very sad it's not
Paxton like he deserves so much more
credit than he gets Bill Paxton the
greatest brilliant likable actors like I
was thinking about Tombstone the other
day I mean he's he makes that movie a
lot of way like two guns with Mark
wallberg Andel Washington he plays the
villain in that and he is he is the
slimiest CIA agent he's just he he
steals that film as well and you a film
with Mark Walberg and Denzel Washington
who do not slouches and he kills it he's
AB he's not even in the main timeline
for Titanic and he makes the other
timeline interesting like it's he's just
good at what he does rest not the
greatest ever Liv but he's a likable
actor yeah the most he's kind of like
Ray Stevenson was you know if if you
need him to do a job he's going to do it
and he's gonna do it damn well yeah I'm
Hudson sir he's Hicks yep yeah so number
voyagers don't know anything about it
sorry sir I don't know anything about
that either I have no idea I'll give it
middle
Musical musical 75
beautiful come
on yeah sure it's also just anounce so
I'm gonna give it a palm yeah uh is
filming I pressed something
there I'll take it Thriller well if it's
a thriller well Borderland is what I was
thinking of when I was talking about
Bioshock sorry I've seen some of the
early shots of Borderlands and um it it
I think it's going to be quite
interesting some of the early
sort of
CGI it's gonna be a good looking film
but I know a little bit about the story
I played Borderlands a little bit and
I'm not quite sure how it's gonna work
but yeah that's yeah maybe great cast
great cast
yeah
so8 this because I love the actor I love
I love Aaron Taylor Johnson but I'm
somewhere between not liking it and I'm
just excited I'm going to I'm I'm
excited to make a video about it yeah
whether you're trashing it or not
exactly I because I do love Aaron Taylor
Johnson and Chambers you know Chambers
right uh he's he's a neighbor with Aaron
Taylor Johnson buddies so like I I love
the guy I just I don't like the way the
studio is making a Peter Parker movie
without Peter Parker and they're making
Craven the hunter a pacifist doesn't
make any sense word and get him on the
show don't
we well celebrate
finger cross that's not a bad idea
friend of a friend that suggest that um
I I'll come I think he's great the best
thing Money Train Money Train not Money
Train yeah yeah no yeah no uh not Money
Train Sandra um Su train and Brad Pit
bullet train there we
go it was
fantastic he's such and I hope he gets
bonded I really hope he's bonded I think
that'd be great it'd make me very happy
Spellbound at number 79 though sorry say
what you say that's all right no
worri I don't know anything but it's
post production and I like the name so
I'm giving it a thumbs up well nothing
about
it about breathe at number and that's
gonna be
interesting but it's like a
post-apocalyptic thing again but yeah I
watch it Challengers drama romance and
Sport interesting completed I I'll
probably watch it but it'll it's
somewhere in the
middle 82 Ghostbusters Frozen Empire I
have yet to see afterlife really need to
but I want to and it's a thumbs up for
me I just hope this isn't
rushed this is very
quick I have I have got my It looks
interesting
yeah it's just it's just very quick but
I think it was planned from the original
film
so I'm hoping it's it's it's going to be
all right um I like in
it yeah Dan AR is gonna be in it again I
think they're all going to be in it I
wish I actually use the
um Ecto one from the second
movie yeah they kind of put that all
that new stuff on and it looked
outstanding with with all the
multicolored lights and everything and
uh when they in afterlife when you come
out you got Ecto one and it's just the
one from the first movie it would have
been nice to have like the continuity if
that makes any sense
so they made it a normous though didn't
they but anyway unless we can argue
about Ecto one all
day saying sometimes it's nice when they
normous or was it just simple stupid
yeah I think keep it simple stupid it
was enormous because they added loads of
extra bits on to because it was supposed
to be don't call it a comeback wasn't it
and sort of thing and um so they overdid
it and it was but but it was done on
purpose and it was part of the the the
humor sort of thing yeah but yeah I'm
I'm okay with it going back to strip
down version a little bit I just want to
I just can't wait to see her um fixed up
and shiny once again
can't yeah Rusty and [__] so even though
she was under a cover she still got so
Dusty strange yeah I know but you know
things
happen 83 in the Lost lands an actual
Adventure fantasy and postproduction I'm
in that's all I need to yeah I I've seen
a couple of bits on this I think it look
quite interesting ter
[Music]
um yeah I can't really describe it but
um it's I think it will be interesting
all right well it sounds interesting in
the Lost lands could be post-apocalyptic
could be just kind of like creepy I'm
interested
it's back the afterlife and ghosts and
things if I remember right oh oh
interesting is there a commercial out
already about it uh no I was just
talking to somebody about it okay uh the
electric State at number 84 action
adventure drama post
production sounds interesting I'll watch
it now sci-fi at number 85 again sci-fi
Adventure what drama space
I
watch I know about this as well and I
can't remember somebody told me about
this as well ah my memory I can too many
people talking at me uh Laura looked up
voyagers from earlier and it's the movie
about Carl Sean's love story with his
wife Stars Andrew Garfield and Daisy
Edgar Jones I remember that being
announced I'm very excited about that I
do like Andrew Garfield and his more
when he gets all romancy and kind of
like biopic wise he's he's
good button number 86 moving on players
post production it's a com it's a romcom
so I'll give it a thumbs up that's gonna
be about players in like bles that are
you know players and they it has good
potential with that concept at least
number 87 though was a movie about my
mother-in-law
what it's sci-fi I'm kiding
mother-in-law is
shely um it says completed it's a
biography of
drama I'll give it a thumbs up I don't
know what it is but I I'll give it a
thumbs up Shirley Temple maybe why not
could be a Shirley
Temple I don't yeah number
88 I think that's the one we've all been
waiting
for Doom part two the REM kind like that
for me June no I it I can't wait I'm
like boom I I thought it was great I
prefer the classic the old ones The
Originals the David
Lynch I love me some David Lynch but
yeah the only thing I would say that I
maybe little hesitant about was they
were trying to I thought they were
trying to copy the tone of the original
David Lynch version a little bit and I'm
likeing I think they could have
quickened the pace up a little bit in
places but um but other than that I I
would say beautifully cast stunningly
put together um and the newcast as well
it seems just as beautifully and
stunningly put together I it's great
Austin Butler is gonna be terrifying as
vade rotha this is gonna be an epic once
it's complete this is gonna be this will
be an epic box set you know like this is
one of those films you've got to go and
get the metal sleeve box set sort of
thing and on 4K and well we've always
known June has being a two-part haven't
we and this is going to be three parts
isn't it yeah well villain said he wants
to do
um uh it's not do Messiah what's the
second
book oh I don't know to I think he wants
to do the second book as well and then
he's he's gonna like put it down and say
if anybody else wants to do it do it but
that's that's my job I did my Trilogy
yeah Co love love right we got a couple
of films here that I don't think
anyone's everever heard of Harold and
the Purple Crayon I grew up on that book
no I don't think I watch it no I'll give
it a middle ordinary Angels completed
not sure but it looks cool it looks like
a TV movie yeah kind of looks like
hallar
kindness oh was just I thought that was
that yeah that's another Hallmark movie
hit Pig hit pigs hitting pigs is one of
my favorite things to do can I hit pigs
hit
Pig I didn't think you were socially
allowed to do that I thought I'd get in
trouble if I went and hit a pig action
adventure animated I like it I like it
give we go I don't AR of the king at 93
looks like it's a movie that's going to
make me cry and I'm going to watch it
anyway yeah it's m wall Bing
it it's the one with the dog that he he
follows them along
and
forber red one is in post production and
that has been in post production for I
think a year and we still have to wait a
year for it which is so weird Christmas
does it yeah I I feel like they were
filming it three years ago I feel like
it was preco you know like like I I
don't know but I like some JK Simmons I
like the Rock and you give me a good
action action adventure comedy during
Christmas time like violent night I'm
happy
honestly they still listed it as the
Untitled Alien prequel really don't we
know alen ramul right yeah yeah um and
filming starts in a couple of weeks oh
no filming's already started didn't it
started release
um technicality it's a palm uh head Palm
but it's
it's there's two um article Pages for it
on IMDb one's the Untitled and one's the
official one with the alien Romulus and
it has does have the release date I
can't remember what it was but I think I
got it written down actually uh well
it's not coming but um they started
filming filmed it they finished ages ago
no they I don't think so yeah they
did while we're at it because we're in
the tail end this they my memory was
that they started filming and then the
strikes Hit And They carried
on on INB Pro it says postproduction so
it says it's done filmed it's it has
been
filmed Ah that's
yeah you would think IMDb would be
updated with information wasn't there
that article of Cameron watching the
um the actual movie for uh
approval um I'm not positive but real
quick while we're thinking about alien
are y'all more excited for alien Romulus
or y'all more excited for the Noah Holly
Alien series coming out both I love Noah
Holly the same equal equal for both yeah
I'm with you I I'm really excited for
both of
them alen movie but to see an Alien
series where alen's supposed to come to
earth and the guy that did Legion is
doing it
just love Legion Legion Legion I think
it's my it's my to this day and I don't
know if anything will ever overtake it
honestly it's going to be my favorite
comic book TV series at least for a long
time yeah it was just it's so creative
it it fits Within but it fits within
like you our tour kind of thing I don't
you know it's superhero stuff doesn't
have to be all hippie dippy fancy like
Cinema quality this it can just be fun
but Legion was fun and it just hit the
notes on every single level I needed to
it was so I'm I'm excited for that Alien
series but fedy Alvarez alien
ramulus they must have only had a bit of
Romulus filming them to do it was paused
so filming started in February um and
They carried on when the writer strike
and then the actor strike started
initially because it was it wasn't sag
aftera a lot of them were British actors
and then it was paused in August so
filming stopped but that would have been
I think they did a lot of the CGI work
during the strikes to be honest yeah got
six months worth of filming in so and I
remember reading that when the strikes
ended the actors were like on a plane
straight back so they must have they
must just had the wrap-up stuff done to
do then because I suppose it's been
three months in it since the actor's
strike
ended and post production could mean
they're just doing all the re-shoot
right now too it could be like all right
we've seen what we got let's let's work
on what we need to work on kind of deal
but um yeah I knew the I knew the film
in I knew the filming had paused during
the strike so I was a little bit
surprised but yeah it's makes
sense so Number
96 is Jake Gyllenhaal's remake of
Patrick s's Roadhouse no no no no
oh I'm hesitant with the Patrick sesy
remake but Jake jenha got big for this
did y'all see the clips of him actually
going into the UFC and like the the fake
fight looked real and everybody was
actually cheering on like oh quality
stuff just yeah
yeah oh I don't know oh this could go
either way this could really one of
those this could this could be epic and
it could be bloody awful but it's a bit
Roadhouse the original it's a great
movie but really if you break it down it
shouldn't
be I keep thinking of like like the um
Red Dawn remake I keep thinking that
when I hear a remake for especially when
it comes to um patricky remake yeah
maybe Red Dawn is that movie that my dad
and I would watch like if it was on TV
we watched like it's just one of those
movies I own that version and I do not
own the new version because that is that
that might be the most disappointed I've
ever walked out of a movie theater I was
so angry and I like the cast boring but
it sucked hi that oh yor geek how you
doing
buddy hey hey yor geek we're talking
movies of course he's
here fan of roadh
house I kept calling him the old
Yorkshire G when I kept talking I
haven't spoken to in ages mate you must
say hello um and I couldn't get it out
of my head as soon as I started do like
that's not so so mean following his
channel he's done some pretty good stuff
lately yeah I love all of his stuff only
been following him for like a couple of
months I think so yeah yeah he's done
proper a proper um he's a proper geek oh
yeah proper proper yorkman too proper
yorkman no offense no offense he will
tell you if you don't like something
there's nothing wrong with that oh I've
had a disagreement with him over Rebel
Moon yeah
we're the Polar
Opposites did did he like it or not like
it oh he loved it okay compared to me
hating it and making fun of
it it apparently I'm in
between I liked it more than I thought I
would but that doesn't mean I liked it
I'm kind of did you watch my uh my Rebel
Moon part two trailer reaction no I saw
whenever you were about to do it but I
watch I really I'm not interested but
I'm gonna make a video of it
anyway I I really hope that 4H hour
Cut's better
but just felt long enough as it is I
don't need a 4 Hour cut I'm okay uh but
but talking about moving on I think
we're gonna all want to move on from
Rebel Moon after it eventually releases
as well uh 97 Havoc an action thriller
that is completed yeah um I can't
remember who's in it but this is um
isn't this a I think this is a British
movie it's either and it looked cool I
don't if I remember correctly um it's a
proper um a little bit of a gangster
movie I think isn't if I remember I
might be mixing it up with something
else oh is it a remake of the 2005
Havoc can't
remember Wes I've never heard of can we
get to 99 W wolves I I I feel like it's
not wolves it's Wolves it's different W
haven't spelled the sequel the wolf or
something like that or maybe it's a
different movie I
don't okay oh I remember H about this
being announced I didn't know they'd
actually got as far as making it so okay
post
production but as you were just excited
about number
9 this needs to be as stupid as the
first one or it's I mean this has got to
be made with no money yeah and and like
tle no no no no I'm I'm just trying to
mentally debate whether it's it's going
up or
sideways if they can recapture the glory
of the first one but the problem is they
won't so because the the glory of the
first one is it's I mean nowadays that
would be like a YouTube movie it' be
like the sort of thing that YouTubers
would do and like a weekend for fun and
I think in part it kind of was um it
reminds me of sort of like bad taste or
something like that this like really
amateur but it was supposed to be really
amateur
um oh it could be good but it probably
won't
be that's the I'm gonna go I'm actually
GNA go with that why why do it makes no
sense I don't know why they've done it
Melvin where are you at on
it I don't know to be honest no idea
don't know where I'm at on it well then
shall we
in the list of 100 we've made it through
100 within an hour and 20 minutes we
didn't even hit the hour and a half mark
that's kind of surprising honestly
because 100 a lot I'm and we did talk
about a decent chunk of them so number
100 one of the one of the most
controversial little endings that we had
to
2023 yeah could be released in
2024 we don't know who by yeah they've
sold um somebody and they've done this
thing that they've started doing
recently completing projects and then
writing them off for tax
benefits um and somehow making
money
but coyote versus Agy everybody that
I've spoken to that have seen cuts of it
have said this is brilliant and they
could not understand what Warner
Brothers were playing at it's John Cena
right and it's also Will Forte yeah
anything will for is in abely Epic
apparently
um so and hilarious and all those things
it's the one person I said is everything
you'd expect from this and the title
says it all what you expect is what you
get at 100 miles an hour um I don't
necessarily love John Cena's acting and
everything he's done recently or not
necessarily that I enjoy his acting and
just about everything he's done recently
I don't necessarily enjoy all the
projects he's chosen per se but
Peacemaker is obviously the greatest TV
show ever made
oh like isn't it like Peacemaker future
armor like sorry I I may vom on camera
it's there it's there isn't it it's like
Peacemaker fut armor Peacemaker had the
most potential out of anything that
might maker was amazing it so amazing
that I never even bothered watching
it genuinely amazing so funny I love it
it it oh it has everything that it could
be and then it just decides to be
[__] stupid most of the time there
are some great moments in it I I it the
second episode where it took John Cena
15 minutes to get out of a room and on
off a
roof that it took I think it was 12 to
15 minutes if not it was that might be
an
exacerbation in real time no no I I
counted hurt me um it's genuinely
brilliant and I cannot tell you how it's
the first time ever that I've seen a TV
series has spit up a movie that I
hated passionately I hated suicide Squad
I hated the second one even more um and
and then they they spun off Peacemaker
and I adored it I thought it was great
but it was it is stupid and anybody that
says they don't like it I completely
understand why and I get why people say
they like it too it just it just B in my
cup of tea no I I wouldn't argue with
anybody that says it was rubbish but
John Campbell's got it right there it's
so bad it's good it's it is that type of
thing Peter did bring up it got the best
title sequence it it had a very creative
very fun title sequence I didn't like
the show so it became annoying to me but
it was super creative and original and
that I do appreciate very
much SP off one of the worst characters
in The Movies that's true can we just
have a rick flag prequel please anything
character but it worked in the series
the way the tone of the series and
everything worked so brilliantly because
he's such a dumbass it was just oh it
was just great horrifically violent M
trying not to be violent and then like
it's just it's just glorious but that's
the sort of show that just amuses my
inner child my in a child blow his head
off and and you know and it's like he
fell over and just you know and but it's
it's not the sort of thing I'd watch
twice I will I will admit I wouldn't
watch it twice Freddy Strummer was good
too as uh who what what's the sidekick
name um oh I can't remember but he keeps
um shooting himself getting bad hurt and
stuff
he does play the part perfectly yeah
he's horrendously and again he's just
wants to murder everybody but his gear
just keeps getting hurt all the time um
I I just I really like John Cena in that
type of role he did a film um when he's
uh what was it it's he's with a couple
and then there's another couple and
they're on their um H holiday sort of
thing it's like something
holiday um and he just plays like um a
weed smoking drug addict um oh oh oh uh
when he's the drug dealer and it's Amy
polar and
and yeah yeah yeah but he's next and he
works as a um Wildlife um Ranger isn't
he but he was he was ex-military sort of
thing and it's one Sequel and um oh
something holiday or something um but
but yeah it's such a good film I
actually watched the sequel It's
on Disney is that Disney
plus that's for my wife I'll have a look
at his ddb and I'll tell you what it's
called called in a minute but it's
genuinely really good film went under
the um he's in something new on Amazon
at the moment as well John Cena and that
looks really good as
well freelancer huh because freelancer I
did oh it's not good no isn't it oh it
looks good he plays the part that he
needs to play just fine so that's why
I'm like I still understand his acting
but that's the movie that I'm talking
about when I'm like I don't like his and
Peacemaker that I didn't like his
choices per se um but
thinker he go together in my which one
John Cena and acting what do you mean
did WWE he's been acting for 20
years yeah vacation
fans right well coyote versus Acme to to
round it out I I think it'll be good
couple's vacation there we go um I never
saw it
but yeah it's coup's vacation yeah okay
first one and the second one is just
just as good oh good it's a good like
a um sort of
like you'd expect um oh what's the guy
who he's got the
laugh Seth Rogan Seth ran it's the type
of film you'd expect Seth Rogan to be in
he wrote or something he didn't but it's
it's that type of film kind of like a
neighbors almost yes John are card
carrying actors yeah yeah exactly but
it's just it's just good it's it's it's
like say it's not big it's not clever
it's just good I like to well Will Forte
and John Cena is all you got to that
makes me think that they made it a a
serious attempt at least into making it
kind of like a burden
Frasier Wy coyote Acme type of movie
yeah and and that fingers cross please
because that stuff's
great is there any what's the what's the
thing that you most sort of if you had
to pick one excuse one film out that
year go
on the ones that come to mine are dunu
and naratu just off the top of my head
uh very different reasons of course for
both I got three oh that's a shame Curry
he's not a great actor he's also isn't
he John Cena though isn't there some
rumors he's not the nicest person in the
world yeah I think so rumors he's a bit
of a in real life he always comes across
really nice and Goofy and like
self-deprecating in interviews but I've
heard a few people I've heard a few
things saying that he's not he's not
that nice a guy and he loves himself
he's very I his so but any I just like
I've liked a few films he's been in
yeah is it blockers I quite like that
blockers with the with the rooster in
front I thought that such a good when I
used to watch
wrestling is it when he sort of broke
out of wrestling started acting like uh
was it the marine and stuff like that I
watched that because that was an action
flick and at time I was interested in
action more than anything else so say
that he's that John Cena is allegedly a
huge dick that wor I don't get sued but
um I have heard that yeah he's that he's
not the guy in the
world Mark says his top two are Dune two
and Deadpool 3 respectable too very
respectable what were your top three
Melvin well my top three um actually
Deadpool three
Godzilla Godzilla X Kong new Empire and
alien Romulus hey that's a good one top
three uh Alien Romulus films I'm
actually GNA go to the cinema to watch
like 100% like if the wife doesn't want
to go I'll go me own I don't
care watch them but it's just difficult
for me to get there it's it's a long way
to
go to the top you want to rock and roll
sorry I had to finish later sorry I
interrupted Jay I was rude you no right
I'm just G I'll just you at
so that's
it that's fine um June two I'm
definitely seeing the cinema I love the
first one I think it's great Nas fararu
100% I'm going to the cinema to watch
that movie I just think it' be amazing
and you know what I am G to go to watch
Twisters at the cinema I love movie and
but I think for me that's a cinema movie
that's the type of movie you've got to
go to the cinema to watch it will not be
the same on you I can watch deadp
Deadpool at home and it'll be all right
I'll be fine with that um Twisters will
not have the impact and that type of
film will not have the impact at home it
just it just won't um unless you kind of
surprised
said the headset and the speaker and the
headphones where you could drown
everything else
out yeah oh and
Ghostbusters because I'm a massive
Ghostbusters fan I freaking love it
um and uh and I me alien is Big with me
so I exclusively dropped on on side
check that um ghost buses 2 had been
Greenland nobody else knew I
knew just
saying any opportunity I can just to
plug that I get occasionally get things
right from time to time
highlight well obviously you drop things
on like YouTube but do you ever tweet
about it after you drop things on uh
YouTube because you could definitely
build a a a group of people there I
never do I've never done that so maybe
should to do it yeah maybe I should
start doing that I need important news
but I'm not gonna tell you because I'm
not allow yeah oh that is annoying I
know I'm so sorry there are so many
things I know that I'm not allowed to
say it's maddening um I forget some of
them because I just have to push out my
brain because I'm not allowed to say
because like say the source will be like
you can't tell anyone because they'll
know who's told
you something is really moving just one
problem can't tell anyone yeah you can't
tell anyone um uh what was it called
trying to think if there's something I
wasn't allowed to tell you at the time
and I'm allowed to tell you now
I knew about the babyon 5 animated movie
about two months before it was
announced and I wasn't allowed to tell
anyone because um I
don't you
think no because I don't think I can
tell you I think he's they still might
get in
trouble anyway I the person that I spoke
to that told me about it had directly
worked on it um and it was not
production it was a oh
man but I knew about it very early on
anyway we'll tell you that and then I
wasn't allowed to say anything um
because you know my favorite was was
Jordan Peele the that was my favorite
little [__] you know for a
while well that conversation happened
and he's about how his next film is g to
be his
most um yes krie she spelled it right
that time well done Carrie good girl
can't be more patronizing um always
right in capitals uh except when I'm
wrong but then I will tell you um but
but yeah um the Jordan Peele thing was
fascinating and it it was it came down
to I've been told a little bit since
then to be fair that he he was the one
that pulled out um because um they
weren't willing to give him the element
of control he wanted so um he was
basically saying oh I'd love to do this
i' love to do that and they were like oh
we've got script we've got development
work done we've got this we've got that
um and he kept and and apparently just
like so he just sort of went I'm not
going to get the I'm not going to get
the controll I want so I'll just do my
own movie um but apparently it came that
close it was it was close that that that
that was who they wanted and he's a
massive MGM fan he's a massive thing
apparently he's quite close to some
people that worked on Stargate initially
as well and he's
like there lots of reasons why he was
interested but it would have been such
just an Eclectic choice that it would
have been fun I I mean left field in a
lot of ways but obviously if he's got
the ties to do it that that just would
would be nice at the same time and he
would do it in a way that nobody else
would do it which would be nice yeah but
also like because I think it would have
been cool for him to I would have seen
it as like it's a project to pay for
other projects I thought he'd have sort
of done that you know sort of like I've
got this moveie I really want to do
right spelberg used to do this all the
time didn't he he would say he would do
a film so that he could do Schindler's
List and he' do something else so he can
do something
else time yeah exactly I did wonder at
the time whether that was going to be
the thing that he might even go to MGM
but I know he's really close to
Universal all his films are Universal
aren't he but I did wonder if it might
be like go to MGM and go yeah I'll do
Stargate but will you fund this you know
um but but yeah no they they decided
against it
[Music]
um
refence J's Wrong I Don't Want to Be
Right do the voice but anyway did did
y'all see that Disney was dethroned as
the top earner Studios this year
Universal out did Disney they haven't
had that happen since
2015 I know but um no un abely smashing
it people forgot about Super Mario Bros
yeah big that got overshadowed too
like I just said recently if a film if a
movie doesn't make a billion dollars
then it's a
failure well
many one film two films were success
this year then yeah only Barbie
and and Oppenheimer Oppenheimer didn't
make a billion in 800
million oh Avatar came out this year as
well didn't it are we saying Avatar came
out this year it it it made a billion
dollars in 2023 but it's not a 202
billion Shazam uh well no
so
Guardians has made more money this this
year than it made when it since it was
released
really is that what black Black Adam
Black Adam I keep thinking it's just as
Shazam because he has made more on
streaming and DVD more money yeah no I
don't think um all Media review s said
what do we think about the Beverly Hills
Cop 3 film Eddie Murphy has a uh deal
basically with
Amazon make
movies
um it's not Bev's cop 3 by the way it's
four yeah uhhuh yeah um he he doesn't
have as big of a deal but it's kind of
similar to Adam Sandler Netflix not a
Beverly Hills movie because it's the
Axel Foley movie True movie but it is
set in Beverly Hills
and holds in it even though he looks
really poorly and he's
like
think be swinging out the back of a Lor
anytime soon no uh well like the first
one with the heat is on playe yeah he's
a bit of a chubby color um I tried to
watch the
last movie and it was Bloody awful that
Candy Cane Lane thing wh which movie
Candy Cane Lane it's awful it's
Christmas movie had out at Christmas and
on
universal I didn't watch it because what
was the movie that he had with Jonah
Hill at the beginning of the year where
he played the dad to the girlfriend and
Jonah Hill was the boyfriend uh the D
yeah uhhuh I saw the out but no I didn't
watch
it well Jonah Hill and and and the
actress didn't even kiss at the end in
like their marriage scene which spoilers
sorry uh but they you could tell it was
a CGI kiss and you're just like so the
actor like would you B A Kiss why would
you bother making this movie why Would
you bother doing the story like if you
want to do a fake kiss there's ways to
do it with your hand and make it look
real in camera and be just fine about it
yeah you get your Thum and you do that
you I
mean I don't remember does anybody
remember in the chat because I don't
remember exactly what it was but it was
it was I remember the advert and I
remember going immediately I'm not
watching that crap I I watched it it got
halfway through and just was like I I
think I need to hit like another seven
dabs to make this okay like you
know no I remember seeing the advert for
it and I'm was like no I'm not watching
that um and I just thought as well it's
just like this is going to be loads of
like racial jokes and things and why is
everything you drink out of so
big no he's
not it's a normal sized cookmate he's
tiny he's Harris is only he's he's he's
like three foot four tall I'm a harb I
mean that it's actually a Lego mug yeah
is actually a Lego hat that's what I was
just going to say it's actually a Lego
hat from a Lego set how do you know
there's Playmobile it's a Playmobile hat
from Playmobile set I drive the uh kid V
VC not the VC cars RC cars whatever I'm
trying to say uh to work most days that
film last year with the Matt Damon where
they go Shunk size was it downsizing
downsizing that happened to Harris he
was in that film but they didn't bother
stretching him back out I was honey
I Murphy and Jonah Hill I'm not I didn't
watch it bad um I actually thought woke
and turned it off and I hate that word
but you know what I mean I was like no
that film's gonna make me angry he hates
it but he still says it well at least
candy cane Lan was better than no one I
don't think anyone I think people have
started to change the way they say it
they don't say woke anymore they just
say the
message oh yeah yeah yeah like critical
Drinker and all that I I I do kind of
like the message more than woke it is
kind of fun funny well I don't like
the yeah don't the message I know okay
just leave it I think it encapsulates it
better and it kind of hopefully will
mean will make make woke mean what it
used to mean down the
line that would be nice it just feels
like it's um some very clever people at
Fox News or whatever when let's
reappropriate this word and that just
makes me angry it's just Lees a bad
taste in my mouth
but um the message yeah I don't mind
that so much um and it's true because at
the end of the
day just like in every other any every
other time ever there are propaganda
movies they just are or there are films
where the writer is so determined to
tell you a story as to get his point
across he forgets about the story a
little bit yeah um or she Kishi the
whole problem with with the industry
right now is the fact that they're
forgetting about the audience they're
just the message is there that's it
that's all they're thinking
about I don't know if they're forgetting
about the audience but they don't care
about the
audience I know I don't think that's
true for a second because they care I
mean no they care about money and the
audience is secondary to that don't get
me wrong but they care about money and
you can't say that I these woke people
keep talking about oh these Executives
all they care about is spreading their
um leftist or rtist or whatever it is
bloody propaganda and I'm like no all
those Executives care about is money
they want your money I they're talking
so against it now and S to talk about
changing things is because they've lost
so much in the last few years well no
they have so they have to like mix
things up yeah we know that we Marvel at
the moment look at look at the adverts
for Echo and they they have repeatedly
say in in those trailers that this is
Marvel starting again Reinventing itself
refining itself
they um you see it but um thank you
Carrie go and check us out on patreon
where most of my videos Premier first
I've got that Spiel that I put at the
end of every video and I've memor and
don't forget to hit that
like yeah don't forget that like button
um doce if you can don't do it twice
because that'll undo it won't it if you
you'll do it and then you'll undo it do
it two or three times but do it on all
but you can down well but yeah you know
and follow us on hit the like there
should be another one like with the side
angle yeah there should be one and then
there should be that one as well when
you don't know why the video ever
actually happen it's only a matter of
time to do moton anyway I know what the
I think I know what the problem is with
Hollywood at the moment has been for the
last 15 20
years
they no they make vanilla movies and
they make you know ready salted what do
you call ready salted I don't like
vanilla I like ready salted but I don't
like
vanilla the point is everybody likes
vanilla because it doesn't taste of
anything it's what they're trying to do
is make movies for everyone and what
they're trying to do offend anyone but
what you end up doing is making a film
that has no substance to it the Marvel
movies are a perfect example of this
that they are trying to keep everyone
happy and by doing happy well they piss
a load of people off and I think that's
been a problem in movies they are so
scared I keep saying that they're scared
of being called anything is they're
scared of being called racist sexist
anything elist and that's been happening
probably about 25 maybe 30 years now
nearly because I do think in the late
90s this started happen um I remember
Kevin Smith released his movie Dogma
which is about Christianity which isn't
negative towards Christianity at all but
the Christians came out and trashed it
and it actually ended up doing okay it
actually was a bit of a mix really
because in the mid in the middle of
America nobody went to watch it because
they all thing but and all the rest of
America went the Christians hate it
watch this Kevin Smith movie and so it
sort of like was a double-edged
sword but I I honestly think that's the
big problem with the big studios but I
can kind of understand it if you're
spending $200 million on a
movie you're GNA be tempted to go that's
gonna
upset $200 million on a
movie it's minus one minus one well
that's the thing should we go brings
that whole question back in the scenario
is should more more movies be $200
million like like they are like you said
a minute ago if you have $200 million
and then probably $250 $300 million with
post production re- shoots etc etc then
you have to budget I mean Market the
whole thing and then account for that
budget you're having to reach almost a
billion dollars if 800 to 1.2 billion to
actually make a profit somewhere is that
even feasible nowadays we should go back
to the smaller film like minus one
that's doing I think they've got to I
don't think there's going to be a choice
well $15 million for Godzilla minus one
and like like whether there's a bunch of
monsters or not in
Monarch every penny of Godzilla minus
one is utilized more than any episode of
Monarch Monarch
is but they're actually releasing Black
and White Version yeah I'm excited for
that I think it's gonna be really cool
it it kind of made me think of parasite
when they did that and I I think that's
sick but the fascinating thing is the
way they've done it they've gone back
and they've done every single scene
every every single layer is done in
black and
white completely
changed beautiful I'm glad I didn't see
the colored one because I want to see
the black and white
one The Nostalgia level alone from when
I was a kid seeing
Godzilla in black and white for the
first time in
Japanese true the cinemas though um
insiders and everything and they're
predicting that next year
um that anything up to a billion dollars
could be wiped off this year's ticket
receipt or last year's ticket receipts
and I think it only went past about n
billion in the US so they're talking
about a billion dollars less that's
enormous films can then go to streaming
but the streaming Wars are done you know
they everyone
lost so that's not going to be the way
to do it Netflix and people we're going
to get these super bundles I think over
the next couple of years and that'll be
amazing
but that you can't get movies keep
losing money like they are they just
can't so um you can industry can't
sustain sustain itself unless it makes
those movies they've got to start making
movies that gonna cost less than hundred
million dollars all um look Indiana
Jones and last and the dial of Destiny
other than the end which is bloody awful
it's a it's not a bad film and it's did
really really well when went on the
original plan for that go on where they
were gonna have
um short route in it he was gonna come
in I would have that that would have
been awesome he gonna be through the
whole movie that would have been awesome
I would have loved that um so but I mean
that movie cost $300 million to make
yeah and then got the um you've got the
thing afterwards there was another
hundred million dollar advertising and
everything else so that's $400 million
you got to make back before you do
anything else remembering that you don't
get all the ticket receipts everything
that money gets money at the box office
you don't get all that nope um
so that film was never gonna make money
they need to stop doing it it did well
it's made its money back now because on
digital release it did really well
people bought it but nobody's going to
go to the cinema and it will still be
considered a massive flop because it
bombed at the cinema and that's the
thing isn't it when we're talking about
Stargate coming back and people are
stressing when I've again dropped the
first news that they were talking about
a budget of around $70 million and I'm
like no I'm more than happy with
that that's still
money 70 to 120 million I think is a
sweet spot I think that's just kind of
like 100 120 that can be your
Blockbuster you can bit 100 over 100
million for a movie I think unless
is like Avengers Infinity war andame
that made
sense
yeah one you spend money on um dial
desent has actually more than made its
money back on on the digital release on
its own um the digital release
particularly in America did very very
well um and then they put it on Disney
plus um which again Disney I'm more than
happy about so um
more I've been tempted to watch it
because I haven't seen it but I I
haven't wanted to see it until now I was
gonna me anything because I don't
although I'm subscribed to Disney plus I
don't actually watch that many Disney
stuff I I watch notic stuff like um when
I was a kid I used to love dogy Hower MD
they got that you know a lot of the old
stuff or teranova it's all on Disney
Plus
yeah I watch Mostly Fox stuff on Disney
it's mostly Fox stuff I watch and I
don't watch lot Disney well especially
now Hulu on Disney plus like that's just
gonna I think that'll really
help K is trying to tell you to
advertise yourself CAC West okay Melvin
we need your channel
sir I haven't added it I haven't added
links to my description I apologize but
I was a bit rushed today and I recorded
a video before doing this with a with a
interesting Stargate update and then
when I got to the end I looked back to
the corner and realized I hadn't
recorded any of
it oh I hate that I hate that talking at
a camera for about 15 minutes and you
just realized you've done that you're
just like
ah yeah I've done
[Music]
it something that's happened to me
recently I start recording a video and
I'm talking about an article and I'm
going through the article but I can't
see streamyards in front of me when I'm
reading the article and when I finished
when finished recording it then I
realized that through most of the video
the article doesn't appear on the screen
and I'm like this little bit in the
corner too late now I'm not going
through it again it's funy streamyards
could if they had a way to scroll
through articles from the uh screen that
you're looking at it would be great it
be great I only use stream because I can
green screen while I
record so um so I mean like I can I do
it now but it might mess up my own
thingy and this is a little bit of an
insight there into how I make videos so
I can green screen myself while I'm
doing the video and record it you see
how this is already affected because
because the kids are here playing how
you get the destiny I know right I'm go
through um but the problem I have with
streamyard is because of my Wi-Fi if the
kids are here and the Wi-Fi drops out
it it messes it basically like fragments
the recording but when I'm editing it I
can't tell I can only I just typed
something in the chat and it's saying
this comment has failed to
post it's going on
here that's the one y um but then when I
when I then Lo upload the
video it kicks in and that's when you
see me going and then my voice kicks in
afterwards but I only know and you know
what it only ever happens if I forget to
check if I don't every time I check it's
always fine every time I forget to check
I will immediately get a message on
patreon going videos out sync like damn
it see if you don't check the Call of
Duty Wi-Fi takes over did you mean
2014 yeah in 2014 yeah I got so many
comments on that oh I know I saw and
I'll I'll pretend I didn't do it on
purpose yeah was about to say I know
you're doing things like that on purpose
that's the way to do it
uh sorry I make mistakes but every so
often I make mistakes on
purpose I know I'm
sneaky I don't know if it's huum or H
huum but he just said so to
Schrodinger's chat and shinger
chat or Alive
babying something to do Shing his
cat all the above Nate from Down
Under good day mate a onean show is how
I was talking to him about this and and
they're saying your YouTube channel
because how many people have you got
working for you
none people who are they what
people because I can get people Harris
has more people in in involved in his
channel but well he's got friends but I
I got Max that helps
like the technically stuff but other
than that I do all my videos myself I
edit my videos because do your
thumbnails yourself
yeah I'm not gonna pay someone to do it
that would be stupid I don't get enough
money from YouTube as it is well you got
have at least a few hundred thousand
subscribers before you have enough money
for that and but they like ah because
he's got a YouTube channel I won't say
who it is because not fair but they've
got a YouTube channel because all I do
is record it I don't do anything
everything else is done by like the team
um I'm like I haven't got a team so then
he's like oh fair play I understand why
your videos are a
[__] you have a managing director though
your
wife um I she likes to be called um yes
she do like to be called her
indors she likes to be called sweet
cheeks I like that I love it she loves
it when I call her sweet cheeks I bet
she loves it when you call her
boss she just loves it when I call her
sometimes
are you having a pint how
many uh glasses I'm on
six you
call you say I'm having a pine and she
say hey my howmet he just say well hang
on
wa that in Gall your life
[Laughter]
J I um I I today my wife come down right
and um she's like looking for the tools
she started taking the Christmas
presents down she was off today
Christmas present the Christmas
decorations and everything down I'm
sorry um she start
deorations yeah yeah well so she started
to take them all down and she was trying
to get all the batteries out right so
she's um she needed a screwdriver and I
got the tools up here because I've been
doing all this messing around with my
new setup in my in my studio space um so
she comes where's the screw they're down
here so I then did a whole bit goes oh
what you need have screwdriver goes oh
oh can you do that with your delicate
little hands and I just started being
and I just went on and goes of course
I'm not sure about this honey I think I
think you maybe need maybe you need to
show me what you need to do and I and
I'll come and do it because I the man oh
she did not find it funny at
all not not even for a moment and then
she punched me in the testicles and I'm
not Jing because I went all right so I
what made me think about so I go all
right sweet cheeks did you um did you
get that job done or is there something
I now need to fix and she went and
flicked her hand
out oh come
on
Jewel right in the just one she caught
one it's like almost like those little
towels you just roll up the towel into
the rat tail
and oh I'm always well deserved yeah
John yeah it was very fair enough really
but I'm always whining her up because
she's very independent lady my wife and
she likes um we're still you know we
still have our roles in the house
because we we're like I'm quite I tried
to be quite you know um a modern man you
know and I'm like and I do most of
cooking in this house because my wife
just gets stressed she can't do it so
she just she doesn't like it it winds
her up [__] gets burned so um so I do
most of cooking um but she does all the
washing and you know we have our roles
sort of thing um but every so often I'll
sort of wind up about not been able to
drive or some just you know just like
that you know just
normal you you guys know me I I think
things are funny in my brain and I say
them and then I forgot I sometimes
forget to tell people I'm joking so I
get in trouble quite a lot um I did I
was joking in a new job actually years
ago and I was joking that um men were
still earning 20% more than women and I
went well we've got to though haven't we
because you know we have to pay for
things like Valentine's Day and um and
like um Mother's Day and stuff even we
got dates
anniversaries we have pay for all this
crap that we don't want to do so it's
only fair not only that but you have to
pay for what they give you as well yeah
we mean um my wife earns twice what
I
anyway yeah but I was cracking this joke
dead pan completely dead pan and then I
walked out of the room and then I came
back to have my mate going off for God's
sake he was joking one of the other was
ready to go complain about me to the
managers call me a sexist pig and I was
like no it was a joke I was
joking take a breather take a
breather why are men paid 40 to 50% less
at
wimon no idea mate no
idea oh is that because oh this because
they play less technically they they
play more tennis so they actually get
paid less they get paid more than women
still don't they but there was a big
argument to say that women should be
paid equal and they were like uh you
only play three sets and we play five
so they should pay him by the
hour gives hourly wages 725 minimum wage
if I'm gonna wear a
dress for 18 hours
dresses I deserve to get paid for every
hour at streams on
online so the price money is the same is
it uh I remember them arguing that they
wanted um similar pay but I didn't know
they' got it but I don't watch Tennis
who cares about tennis um unidentified
did you build an X-Wing out way Benjamin
for one Benjamin is watching thank you
sir so you know I'm setting up my little
I'm doing a little thing so I've bought
myself a little Star Trek model oh cool
and um and a couple of things I've got a
Stargate thing coming and I've got have
so when I do lives I'm G to have this
little little thingy background right um
my lad has been building my an xwing
model and hours Ben if you're watching
mate come and show slave
labor well he was there going oh I've
got a bit of a head I was such a sod he
I've got a headache I don't want to play
on the Xbox anymore and I was like great
I've got this model for you you
go so we spent all day doing
it he just got hyper focused on it was
like see good see you oh it's big as
well oh man look at that jobby oh wow oh
wow how good's
that good Lord that's good looking out
way I like the weathering on that yeah
yeah it's good right so that's G to be
my uh it's gonna be like that's red five
as well definitely red five nice one
good job
siring that is outstanding is it that is
great it's
cardboard this oh god I've broken
it i' broken it
already and he couldn't do that I had to
do it it was a night
man but how epic is
that I might have broken it a little bit
oh
God he's got the stream he's got he's
walking outside and he's got the stream
on he
knows yeah
um will we be able to right I tell you
what just as we've got 30 people
watching we're at the twoh hour
Mark I've got the video coming out
tomorrow um the boss of Amazon is Mike
Hopkins he's the boss of Amazon video um
there was a meeting yesterday with
Jennifer salky at which he told Jennifer
salky stop messing around we need this
MGM stuff I want something to announce
now but he wasn't just talking about
starg some Bond and everything as
well Robocop Robocop returns it'll be
the actually the proper RoboCop sequel
that we were promised all those years
ago and which is gonna be awesome
um sorry Legally Blond three blond three
um 2001 Space Odyssey streaming series
potentially um or the sequel it will be
2010 you do that to a to a is it GNA be
a sequel is a third movie or a sequel
it'll be a sequel to the yeah to the
third there's three books I think it's
the third book so um but it'll be a
streaming series potentially interesting
okay and and the other was Forbidden
Planet so uh properly doing Forbidden
Planet and
space the search for more money um but
not gonna be the search for more money
though is it
should be it should be because it's
actually a quote from the first movie I
love that movie yeah that's why I say be
with you at the end of every movie I do
every video I do now I my prediction I'm
standing by by prediction at the moment
um and this isn't based on anything
because over Christmas period everybody
goes home and I've heard a few bits as
of coming back sort of things so I'm
starting to hear rumors again now but
basically everything after Thanksgiving
it's Christmas I'm drunk now I'm gonna
exactly I accidentally typed a message
yeah when I was drunk I can't remember
can't remember I wasn't there when I did
it
um I I'm sticking by my thing that it's
going to be announced at San Diego Comic
Con it'll be a movie and it'll
start um production in the summer it'll
be so cool and we're all there at the
announcement yeah that would be amazing
um I'm I'm doing my best to go um I I
think that will work up because I think
that's when I'm hearing Amazon are
getting a bunch of Studio space that
this this company that's building Studio
space for a lot of them start coming
online um early and late a lot of the
waiting though isn't that's why we're
waiting so long is because they need to
have all that space built yeah well it
was kind of around the
um so this is this is one guy's opinion
who works on the he doesn't know this
for certain but it was his opinion and
his basic opinion was he's saying that
they were planning to do the movie but
it was going to be with a partner um and
then they would have had to rent the
studio space basically and it would have
added almost 10% onto the production
cost yeah but now they but now they're
not basically they're they're paying
rent partially to themselves by having
partnership with the company aren't they
well they would have had to rent Studio
space from a third party basically but
now they've got a
longal yeah with Hackman group Hackman
are building sets for Amazon and then
they're going to rent Amazon but also
Amazon are are one of the big investors
in the Hackman group yeah so they're
kind of themselves and but there's loads
of tax reasons why a good idea to do it
that way rather than actually building
your own Studio space but um so
basically they saidas to do it in Canada
yeah a lot will be done in Canada but
the thing is they've got to do some of
it in America because Amazon promised
when they pretty sure there be a
percentage has to be done in the United
States yeah there was some backdoor
agreements when MGM bought Amazon Amazon
bought MGM about production costs it's
actually based on money apparently they
have to like spend so much money on
production each year in America um so he
his argument was basically look the
studio the strikes happened so it
delayed everything by six months anyway
and then when they were coming back
Amazon were like we can save a crapload
of money here if we wait if we just wait
until we've got the shio studio space
we're going to save 10% of our
production costs when you're talking
about 100 million doll movie at least
that's $10 million and then you're
talking about 20
films you know that's like it starts
adding up pretty quickly yeah that's the
mindset I want from the studio too is
like I I want them to be worried about
what their where their pennies are going
and make sure that you make sure they
have the most efficient use of each and
every penny like that 70 to 80
million perfect for a budget because it
kind of forces the filmmaker to kind of
all right well maybe we don't do
something so crazy and we kind of make
it more realistic or make it whatever
may be something more uh story or
character developed whatever it may be
Legally Blonde 3 is the Pinnacle of MGM
we're just all waiting for I want it
with Dan CR that would be epic that
movie damn it as long as you got Reese
in it I'll watch
it
what
awesome but um guys we've been talking
for over two hours now I want to go
watch
Yellowstone where are you atting It
season four episode
three or four so Jimmy's just gone down
to
Texas the old fella has got his he's got
got beat up I can't remember his name
Kevin yeah but everyone's not dead so
it's all good that's good I'm actually
gonna go and watch a a two-part movie
which is actually about Yellow Stone
it's called super volcano oh
cool yeah
cool Direction the breeze is Flowing so
I can go either further west or go to
the Gulf Coast I think those the only
place that I get to
survive I I was speaking to a
volcanologist new saying if the super
volcano at Yellowstone does go off which
is gonna talking to a
Vulcan yeah no Vulcan a vulcanologist um
he was actually saying it would reverse
loads of the um global warming it would
actually be a good thing for the world
um it's just America that's trou because
most of it will be on fire like that's
that's not an even all thing that's not
like a I know America's on fire but the
rest of us are all right it's not we
fine we might get a few heavy snow win
heavy cold heavy Winters and stuff like
that but we'll be fine is attitude was
well go Silver Lining it's not a silver
lining America people
dead ground or
something super volcano do the
prediction of where the ash cloud is
going and it's going all the way across
is what do you call it the agricultural
part of the United States is it the the
Grain Belt or something yeah uh well
yeah the Midwest typic Farmland was
going to get covered in Ash and it was
going to be
unhirable
yeah we love
America there are reasons I claim Texan
before I claim
American well America is the greatest
country on Earth and it was I mean God
loves America most and we have to say
that because most of the audience would
probably be American 50% of my audience
is
Amer get more views on my videos if I do
them after two o'clock in the
morning yeah I don't know why it's just
weird I
know
okay no America God loves
you God loved you I would tell everyone
I was Canadian if I visited the world if
I went anywhere I'd go oh you from
America nope Canada literally that's why
I say Texas they're way more
fond people aren't gonna argue with you
because you they think you're going to
shoot them if you say it's great there's
a nice Advantage America but I've wanted
to wear a red
jacket and
sing I have a kettle
drum ah
I was say I know a couple parts of town
that you do not want to be going
anywhere wearing a red jacket we're
coming baby here we are I still can't
believe that I went to America At Last
Christmas and nobody was waiting going
yay sidet trk and nothing got nothing
it's New
York No Love No Love in New York baby
well New York doesn't have love for much
so it's okay nothing like the Beatles
damn it anyway um guys we
have the main writer of Yellowstone I
don't know a
c sci-fi writer was the main writer
writer Yellowstone in an episode wait
can you reword the question yeah what
sci-fi was the main writer of
Yellowstone in an episode of oh so
Taylor Sharon is an actor as well and he
was one of my favorite characters in the
early seasons of Sons of Anarchy but
what
scii I know let me see let me remind me
his
face Sheridan what
if Taylor Sheran ever watches this
please hire me for the Yellowstone
spin-off do I need to do much else I can
ask up much room
either don't know doesn't say early life
career
he thank you
Nate Josh Brolin in Toro I love that
what are we looking up
again what what signi he was in oh there
we go that's what we were looking up you
give me 20 seconds I I will squirrel
it's it's bad I can't see
anything it was just in an episode of
something was he I can't see an I can't
see a photo of the man damn it is it is
it recent R can you give us a
hint someone wrote an episode of
Yellowstone that has a Sci-Fi background
no the writer of Yellowstone the guy
that made it is also an actor it was one
episode in a Sci-Fi what right got his
got a picture of the man oh is that is
thaty that wrote it because he's in
loads of the episodes he plays the um
one of the things I don't know him from
any Sci-Fi
movies oh yeah yeah I guess he's in part
of Yellowstone episode of a SciFi I
think
oh SFI I don't recognize
him anyway don't do do we was it an
SGA if he was an SGA I I'll have died
for a moment if he was in SGA and we
don't know you're screwed
xil know who it is move
on SGA is my favorite
S1 is very close to Star Trek which one
who did he play in Star
Trek which star one episode of Star Trek
old Star Trek or new Star Trek because
it was new Star Trek I don't care if was
in Discovery I probably didn't watch it
he was an
Enterprise was he one episode in 2004
what episode what was it called he
played jerub I am not sure jerub he play
a red shirt did
he that means he
died had blue jumpsuits was he one of
the um soldiers was he one of the like
the Marines or something why do I know
that name that name stands out why does
it stand out J it jerb jerb
jerb it's an alien I think it's got to
be an alien chosen
realm anyway guys I want to go please
let me he an alien
I just Googled it cool excellent I
please let me
leave it's
been it's been
great it's great to be back on your
channel channels a video where for most
of it we went I don't know anything
about that for most of this video and
we've still had over 30 people
watching I feel like we knew it was
probably about 30% though it was
probably 30 but Nate said still very
strange to be around in a live stream
for the last 20 minutes I've I've been
here it has been fun and hopefully there
are
more a great Lads Lads you can come back
Wednesdays and Sundays for sure but we
know who knows just keep your eyes out
yeah yeah but we do the in scoop we try
to do it every Wednesday we've not been
great in the run up to Christmas but we
Tred
and but it will be on Harris's Channel
it will not be on Sid Trek normally
occasionally we
will that one that one yeah um and so go
over and subscribe to Harris damn it if
you want to see the C scooper we talk
about the movies and everything don'tget
Harris also has
gcubed well we got a gcbe thing going
later so if you want to watch schmook
play some Call of Duty 5:00 Central
Standard Time you mean what schm gets
shot in Call of Duty a lot yeah because
his actual Marine friends are playing
with him so I expect actual Marines to
shoot better on video games than people
do that aren't actual Marines as well
just naturally right they're kind of
like Airsoft when
it's go over see the Y geek as well even
though has been live for about 16
minutes
yeah guys byebye byebye everybody great
way to start the year oh yes oh yes left
so
good see you next time